[Music]
one of the kingdom's most prosperous
merchants has been exposed for his
corrupt dealings nearly all of his
riches are invested in a collection of
30 exquisite Burmese rubies and the
crowd in the square is clamoring for
their confiscation to reimburse his
victims but the scoundrel and his allies
at court have made a convincing case
that at least some of his wealth was
obtained legitimately
and through good service to the crown
the king Ponder's for a minute and
announces his judgment because there's
no way to know which portion of the
rubies were bought with ill-gotten
wealth the fine will be determined
through a game of wits between the
merchants and the Kings most clever
advisor you you're both told the rules
in advance the merchants will be allowed
to discreetly divide his rubies among
three boxes which will then be placed in
front of you you will be given three
cards and must write a number between
one and 30 on each before putting a card
in front of each of the boxes the boxes
will then all be opened for each box you
will receive exactly as many rubies as
the number written on the corresponding
card if the box has at least that many
but if your number is greater than the
number of rubies actually there the
scoundrel gets to keep the entire box
the King puts just two constraints on
how the scoundrel distributes his rubies
each box must contain at least two
rubies and one of the boxes must contain
exactly six more rubies than another but
you won't know which boxes those are
after a few minutes of deliberation the
merchant hides the gems and the boxes
are brought in front of you which
numbers should you choose in order to
guarantee the largest possible fine for
the scoundrel and the greatest
compensation for his victims
you don't want to overshoot by being too
greedy but there is a way you can
guarantee to get more than half of the
scoundrels stash the situation resembles
an adversarial game like chess only here
you can't see the opponent's position to
figure out the minimum number of rubies
you're guaranteed to win you need to
look for the worst-case scenario as if
the merchants already knew your move and
could arrange the rubies to minimize
your winnings because you have no way of
knowing which boxes will have more or
fewer rubies you should pick the same
number for each suppose you write three
nines the scoundrel might have allocated
the rubies as 814 and eight in that case
you'd receive nine from the middle box
and no others on the other hand you can
be sure that at least two boxes have a
minimum of eight rubies here's why we'll
start by assuming the opposite that two
boxes have seven or fewer those could
not be the two that differ by six
because every box must have at least two
rubies in that case the third box would
have at most 13 rubies that's 7 plus 6
add up all three of those boxes and the
most that could equal is 27 since that's
less than 30 this scenario isn't
possible you now know by what's called a
proof by contradiction that two of the
boxes have eight or more rubies if you
ask for eight from all three boxes
you'll receive at least 16 and that's
the best you can guarantee as you can
see by thinking again about the 8 14 8
scenario you've recovered more than half
the scoundrels fortune as a restitution
for the public and though he's managed
to hold on to some of his rubies his
fortune has definitely lost some of its
shine if you enjoyed that try out this
variation the King has pitted you
against another scoundrel with a new
challenge this time you have to divide
30 rubies into three piles the scoundrel
will then choose and keep two of those
piles what is the maximum number of
rubies that you can keep
this bonus riddle comes courtesy of our
sponsor brilliant they start with simple
questions that build your intuition ramp
up to problems that entice you and then
help you develop different ways of
solving problems that were previously
out of your grasp to hone your capacity
to think critically visit brilliant org
slash ted-ed and the first 833 of you to
use that link will get a 20% discount
off the annual subscription